familiarity kills respect and in a  romantic relationship even last constant  exposure to the everyday nuances of the  other person may breed the discomfort  and a lack of respect towards the other  person nature logically draws  inspiration for this Maxim from the sad  endings most of his relationships had to  face the struggle is real and it  manifests itself in different ways  throughout our lives I think that the  reason such concerns are expressed so  often is that we usually fail to strike  a balance between pragmatism and  Romanticism these two forces are  mutually exclusive but that doesn't  necessarily suggest that we can't  successfully vacillate between the two  the key here is self-honesty and the  establishment of pragmatic expectations  on all levels of our relationships